Meredith Meredith mary mary had a little
lamb mary Meredith had a little lamb
don't bring that lamb to work or it'll
poop on the floor hey Oscar come on in
what's up uh I'm sorry to bother you
oh no no come on in what's what my
nephew is involved with charity for
cerebral palsy and I was wondering if
maybe you'd like to you know if what
donate to the charity oh god of course I
would get it over here
get that over here thank you no I'm
always good for some serious bucket Wow
$2 $3 people out here do not care about
diseases I'm going to give you $25
that's that's that's very generous Dan
oh gosh well listen Oscar generosity and
togetherness and community all
convalescence is into morale is what I
say so
Jim good party huh a little something I
whipped up you know a little morale
boost no big deal speaking of which I
meant to tell you very impressive the
donation you gave the Oscars charity
when was that 25 bucks no well no money
isn't everything Jim not the key to
happiness you know what is joy you
should remember that maybe you get more
than $3 next time it will $3 a mile is
gonna end up being like 50 bucks
god I can't even calculate where you're
gonna have to you
it's Oscar around I just thought it was
a kind of a flat you know $25 one-time
donation I didn't think it was a per
mile kind of deal you know don't look
that's what a walkathon is I know it
says it right on the shoes look look at
the sheet it says it's however many
dollars per aisle got it yes so it does
I just think it's kind of cheap to
unknown eight money to a charity no no
no no no I wasn't that wasn't what I was
no it's it's not about the money
it's just it it's the ethics of the
thing Oscar how's your nephew see ya
good shape yeah how many miles how you
do last year last year he walked 18
miles son of a [ __ ] that is impressive
you